hello everyone welcome to another
episode of play watch listen I'm a lot
of PS I'm joined by Austin wintry and
Mike Bethel Troy was not able to join us
today devastatingly this is our first
official off the dock episode whatever
that means but we did want to mention
from the jump that going forward as
people's schedules maybe start to ramp
back up a little bit this may happen
from time to time so we'll obviously
just you know from from the top of the
show keep you posted on what's gonna
happen we're open to the idea of like
potentially having other people jump in
but in general the ideal format for this
show is of course the four of us talking
about video games so that's not gonna
change just you know choice busy being a
dick talking about video games and in
this week what in this week's case
talking a lot about Troy yes we will
long we will it'll be a full Festivus oh
it's good that's good it's like he was
here all along he's just looking at
might be in his living room yeah I was
like I should have asked him for that
file something about that angle that
kind of looks like it was taking from
the perspective of a wall like a urinal
cam he's got this
I'm very oculus we are changing our
backgrounds to things that relate to
Troy Baker I didn't even see you do it
Mike that's hilarious that I just really
well I know it really I don't
I've got alternate views as well because
I've I've just had too many video calls
with Troy let me just how'd you get that
shot of Troy on the horse
Alana that's particularly in old video
games I feel like all the time I play
something and I'm like is that [ __ ]
Troy again and it is all the time so
good
very nice angle too good job angle -
it's so good at editing zooms impress
now now it's the moment where you reach
and you pull on your book of like a
coffee table book of the Troy of Troy
voices house tour yeah surely I just
started replaying spec ups the line and
I was like no Nolan you
it's [ __ ] Nolan definitely gets to it
when you're friends with people and you
hear that voices in video games you like
all right Nolan okay two choice credit
though and it's a lot easier to
compliment him when he's not here I
there have been many times where it was
the opposite where I was and I was like
wow this is an interesting voice and
then I was like god damn it's him again
yeah where he really he really chameleon
eclis yeah transforms in a way that it's
hard for me to hear cuz sometimes even
if it's dressed up into a character like
like like hex is a great example that's
not remotely Troy's speaking voice but I
could hear the Troy in the core of it
like I can hear maybe I just know his
voice so well at this point from how
many of these and phone calls and and
hanging out and then just playing all
the games there's you know you kind of
learned that imprint but there's still
ebbing out again I'm like damn that's
yeah I don't feel like he sounds like
Joel very much really at all like I
still I still can't put those two things
together I can't like Troy in most other
roles I hear as Troy but like Joel in
most of us suits which is very cool
meaning I call someone who wants to be
very immersed in that universe that I'm
not like Troy Baker exactly
you shouldn't have to choose you
shouldn't have to choose your
friendships based on which games those
friendships will mess up for you mostly
when I find Troy and something it's a
cool Easter egg I'm like oh it's again
what the hell man like look he just
doesn't always very good always very
good great hair we're all devastated
that his hair is not present I'm
interested well the comments going to be
about on this episode without Troy
provides everyone but speaking of Troy
Baker known PlayStation exclusive we
wanted to talk a little bit about ghosts
this is human did you guys end up
watching me say to play I loved it yeah
I did also yeah I was all I was the -
I'll just get it out of the way because
I suspect Mike will have a far more
interesting analysis but I actually will
between the two of you you'll be looking
okay
well III first off I loved I had no idea
I didn't catch from Twitter for example
from people talking about it actually
it's surprisingly not a lot of chatter
although I haven't been checking social
media as much lately deliberately but
but the the the sort of likes classic
cinema black-and-white ultra windy mode
I thought was such a cool touch so I was
like what a what a love let's have been
samurai mode yeah they like you jimbo
mode you know like I thought that was
such a beautiful I thought it's funny
because the game was strikingly
beautiful and I thought I would be so
tempted to play the whole game in that
black and white mode but but they also
make clear just what you'd be missing in
the process which is an interesting
dilemma because I thought man but then
is also raining the whole time and I
think it adds like some different
dramatic effects maybe it's not raining
the whole time at most of the time like
that that Kurosawa mode as I'm calling
it adds a lot of atmosphere but I feel
like I'll jump between the two a lot cuz
right now in my head when I think it
goes to Tsushima I think of bright red
leaves like that's what my head goes to
right is it probably some of the early
footage that we saw but having that mode
I just want every game to have it now
like Animal Crossing hell yes I'm yeah
it'll be crazy it's just it's so pretty
but okay before we get to the question I
wanted ask that was related to that Mike
what did what did you think of it I was
hyped I think I said like on the last
episode that like I didn't know what the
game was here and I wanted them to just
literally like show me the map screen
show me navigating to a point show me in
a fight room and he just did all of that
no it looks amazing it looks like it
looks like I still maintain that like I
feel like horizon zero dawn was
basically then trying to make like the
Sounion house far cry and this feels
like very much the Sounion house
assassin's creed in the best possible
way yeah lots of tension and tell
yourself guys so like I I looked at in
yeah it's one of those it's one of those
things where you look at it and
instantly like send it on to your five
mates who don't really follow game news
yeah because you're like this is going
to be one of the ones that
yeah I'm really excited about this game
one thing that I wanted to mention that
I didn't notice the first time then I
went through the state of play that I
feel like most people just haven't
noticed is um
ghost swaps the bow at at some point in
combat so there is an animation that
people were saying why does this look so
brutal like it looks like he's just shot
someone it is because he changed bow
types I just feel like a lot of people
miss that so pay attention to the fact
that the bow type changes and thus the
animation changes accordingly
oh very reliable on those minutiae you
know I just I just try to speak for the
people you know that's what I'm really
about you so what I wanted to get into
today but I'm just gonna spring on you
guys is this is an example that that
mode that you brought up Austin which
really stands up my whole segue because
I was in that you know well and I just
got an attack on to that also in the
similar vein the notion of defaulting
they don't actually default they say but
they kind of presented it a little bit
like they were defaulting to the game
being in Japanese with subtitles also
it's like watching anime the dubbed
version again with all due respect to
Troy who I know earns at least some
portion of his living participating in
the redoubling of things like anime I I
to me it's so it's so out of the
character of it and this seemed like
even though you know obviously there's
an enormous number of Americans and
whatnot who work on the game like it
felt like to play it in Japanese the
fact that they acknowledge that up front
that that you playing it with subtitles
is almost like kind of the the sort of
secret main way to play I loved that
that to me felt very related to the they
were very personal about voice actors
for this game i know that i know that
sucker punch was really cautious about
you know not being racially insensitive
because they did get a little bit of
criticism i think for maybe it was
second son just for some of the themes
in that game particularly so they were
really careful and I believe if I
remember being totally three there's
someone had sucker punch who's voiced a
character in every single game that
they've had you just it's just a running
thing that he's just voiced some someone
in every game just kind of a fun I guess
and I think that in this game they
couldn't find a spot for him because
they were like it just doesn't work
can't have you doing an accent it's just
long so they were really really careful
about that stuff but Austin does that
give me it
does that mean you're a dub G sub person
you prefer subtitles from the jump if
it's almost yeah if it's basically
anything not natively in English I would
prefer it be in its original language
because to me the disc can if nothing
else the disconnect between the
performance of an overdub versus
especially if you're talking about a
live-action film that to me that's it's
just unwatchable it's so distracting
even if the performance is independently
good it's just not the one yeah that's
also physically happening and because it
was a mind-blowing to me talking with
you know so much of the rest of the
world is used to watching American films
dubbed into their language that that's
like the default norm and that blew my
mind because I was like I would never
watch a French film dubbed in English or
a Japanese film dubbed in English or
whatever to me and it's not I'm not
trying to be snobbish or something it
just you know it's just distracting yeah
it's it to me so yeah I thought it was
really cool that this seemed to be kind
of built he didn't overtly say the game
will default to being in Japanese he in
fact he seemed to directly say the
opposite but I think that they called
that out in their highlights you know
and if they have less than 20 minutes to
point out some top level things to
attract you the fact that that would be
something they call out was I thought
very cool and about that I'm I would be
inclined of never once changed the
settings on a game in that way before I
did Final Fantasy and Sakura is entirely
in Japanese which works really well for
it so with games like I get it played
Sakura so good I know I know it's just
it didn't really play secre plays did
you find out on reddit doesn't mean
that's quite good yeah I totally agree
with you on live-action but when it
comes to anything animated I generally
care so much about looking at the art
and I have
trouble not reading so like I don't want
to read subtitles I just do all the time
and it's very difficult for me to look
at everything else so for a Ghibli film
for example I'm going to watch the dub
instead of the sub of that because I
would way prefer to be watching me out
the whole time then reading subtitle
justing yeah it's funny maybe I maybe I
am I think yours is probably the more
popular take like I think that I'm I'm
the filthy peasant for being like
sometimes I prefer a dub but it's also
no I mean that's a very good
justification though that's a very good
reason because the artistry is
astounding and every millimeter of the
frame is usually like very beautifully
and carefully I think I I think I kind
of spot check the the subtitles really
rapidly it's funny I my Instagram for
some reason is always full of memes of
from the office it's like I clicked on
one once and now it's just like this is
all you like yes good Matt but there was
there's an episode where where Jan gets
like breast implants and comes in with
this shirt that's like super cleavage II
and so you see her standing there like
you know trying to have a conversation
and all the guys are just sort of
staring at air and it was like you know
the the meme text was like truck you
know like the subtitles versus the show
of like you just can't look away
yeah and I remember saying like that's
like that that I do I did have to kind
of train myself to to spot-check and
then because we were watching recently
rewatched akira i'm great film and yeah
hadn't seen it in fact it may have never
actually seen it entirely it was like I
had seen fragments of it over the years
and convinced myself I had watched it
because there were lots of it that I was
like that super bizarre and I don't
think I ever have seen this before here
is weird as hell it's great I really I
loved it but it was but it's one of
those where yeah I I I was definitely
conscientiously kind of making sure I
didn't miss anything relevant but then
keeping eyes away from the subtitles but
I just couldn't bear it in English
yeah I've derailed you thoroughly know
there's still actually kind of works
what was the second
I had my departed segue topic basically
wanted to talk about was of course
Tsushima has like a Kurosawa mode and I
think they've been pretty blatant about
what that's inspired by and then you
know I recently just watched through all
that the clone was and then I'm after
finishing the clone was ended up
watching a lot of Star Wars reference
watching a lot of interviews about the
Clone Wars where Dave Filoni and George
Lucas are like well this is our Seven
Samurai episode same thing they knew and
Mandalorian this is our Godzilla episode
and the Godzilla episode and coin was is
so obvious that it's Godzilla that
they're parroting like what do you think
what do you guys think of the biggest
biggest collection of those beats that
are constantly remade throughout media
and do you think that there is going to
be a point where video game beats become
something else like is there a world
where the Bioshock moment of man chooses
a slave obeys and and figuring out what
all of that means becomes in other
platforms or do you think that we're too
far removed that video games ever get
kind of repeatedly reworked by anything
other than other video games because I
know like ocarina of time is still just
remade all the time referenced all the
time I probably said it on this show
before but one of my favorites GDC talks
was the Platinum team talking about how
they basically made that game
sorry Nier automata feel good and part
of what they did for deciding the map
size was very much like well what's a
good map size Ocarina of Time so they
just made it the same as Ocarina of Time
and I have loved the idea of doing that
that I've definitely spoken about this
before everything being on Carina of
time this is still absolutely an
influence that we have but when do we
start having our own Kurosawa mode where
which goes outwards yeah like yeah it
escapes just just eternal game or is it
I think it's I think there's an argument
in part it's already happening I think
there's still only think of one I can
think of too so I'll try those so first
off definitely John wick has boss fights
and that was something we definitely
have having worked on John wick we we
talks about a lot both internally and
also
the film guys of like like when they
were filming they conceived of there's a
video game logic to it so that they have
in John wick is video game II yeah like
there's there's definitely like Chad's
not a gamer gamer but he's he respects
and likes games and I think he's there's
definitely a bit of kind of influence
going into there and I think you can
look a job where can go this is a video
game movie and that was definitely
something that I'm taking away from the
stuff I've directly gonna go awareness
of is something like say Game of Thrones
opening with the map screen um that as
admittedly is also as a great debt to
old fantasy books always having the map
on the first page of course but I think
for a modern audience that's that kind
of that understanding of a spatial
relationship is very big and that
introduction being very videogame you in
the way stairs you around I don't think
that's a massive stretch I think there
is that letting that literacy of space
and geography the average kid now can
probably read a map better than I could
when I was a kid because they were
looking at the map screens in these
games all the time and kind of getting a
sense of how this will work that's true
yes like that it's a stretch admittedly
it's a bit of a stretch to be a bit of a
hot take but so the III think I actually
think you'll probably completely agree
with mine because I don't think it's I
don't think I don't well I don't think
it's a stretch because I and here's my
here's my my preview my set up was I
remember when the star of this film went
on The Daily Show at the time to promote
it the first thing out of John Stewart's
mouth was this game this movie is
basically the best adaptation of a game
I've ever seen without it being
adaptation of a game which was Tom
Cruise on the edge of tomorrow the time
cycle was like us for a respawn point or
a save point mechanic and everybody who
watched it seemed to have this takeaway
of it felt very much like a game of
iterate like a like a roguelike or rogue
like almost aware of of iterating past a
save point and and respawning in in
reiterating and
and refining your skills everyone who
saw that movie which was criminally few
people apparently cuz I really get to
think that movie is one of the best
modern sci-fi and based on a manga right
as well like it's I think it's I think
that's maybe that's the connective
tissue together could be I can't you
know now that you say that I think
you're right it does jog a memory that I
feel like I knew that at one point and
forgot but yeah point but but uh yeah
point is that one was one where it had a
very gamey kind of mechanic built into
its premise that even though it has no
direct tie to a game franchise it's not
a movie adaptation of you know live die
repeat the game it is it is something
that people seem to intuitively
understand without needing some big
talky sci-fi well the cronometer 's have
had their polarity reverse ort of thing
in order to justify it it was like this
is just a thing that happens yeah in the
way that a lot of games just present in
that manner that's always my response to
people who asked like when when a
videogames gonna be considered at all
and it's basically throughout history
every new entertainment medium has
become art ii all the people who didn't
grow up with it died and that's I mean I
get a really blunt way like that's when
film was accepted that's when television
was accepted like if you were born into
a world with it you consider it to be
art and media exact same way or I think
that's true of the film industry now
towards games like it's really
interesting walking into those kind of
studios and you know you've done film
work as well stints on you've you've
got--you've overlap for those guys but
like they know games you know that first
meeting with Lionsgate was we want to
make golden but only in the last few
years right because the book is people
have aged into those positions and how
and I think it's the same as true of
film directors you know you mentioned
that movie I think of source code from
Duncan Jones which is a similar kind of
brown have been major gamer and he's a
mega nerd yeah ultra nerd and actually
worked in games for a bit before before
he made moon yeah but yeah anyway did
some stuff and I think that's that
overlap now is becoming just kind of
part of the
the kind of the the reality of it I
think that's that's how you have
influences is you basically just have to
influence enough people during their
childhood that they yeah all you need is
kill is the name of the manga that I
guess inspire all you need is how old is
that is that something because I have 14
volumes I might read that you know 2014
is it's not a big commitment is it 2 vol
you know I love a two-volume when you
find out that open-world game is 15
wasn't the film like 2015 or 2016 like
that's a shockingly fast turnaround for
a pretty big film adaptation maybe so
this happens this yeah this happens a
fair amount now in Hollywood where they
will have these projects that originated
basically where the comic book is the
pitch for the movie and you see that I
think that's I think that was done with
the Noah movie you remember the the
Russell Crowe Noah movie the Aronofsky
yeah yeah like that was a card that was
a graph that was Aronofsky Aronofsky
isn't that strange
I admire anyone who looks at the Bible
it goes needs a rewrite that's a level
of like hubris I admire and then an
oblivion the another Tom Cruise movie it
was also similarly kind of originated I
think it's often like it's a it's a it's
a good stepping stone basically to
producing a visual identity of something
I'm kind of showing imagery to the execs
and going this is you know all those
scripts this is what this is the world
we're creating right right right
to jump back to what you're saying
before Mike about um things become art
as soon as the population ages out I
just this morning did a panel basically
on games and brands and marketing and
how all of that is developing and yeah
one of the questions in the Q&A segment
we got was about why games still aren't
taken seriously being you know the
highest-grossing entertainment industry
in the entire world and the only answer
I can think of
he is ok Puma it is it was a not taken
seriously by that's my question response
nowadays I would say maybe it's
mainstream media like it really is the
older generation it is as you said
people who didn't grow up with video
games who aren't recognizing the
validity of video games and I do wonder
sometimes if some of that is that video
games are still so iterative of other
things and you're right let the people
who grow up now playing video games
might even like I think we will see a
loop of things that are now in film that
are inspired by video games obviously
right amazing example Austin I think
it's looped back yeah I think I think
also because I I think about this a lot
and like that question of you know what
separates the kind of cultural impact of
games versus film when film is still
held broadly on this pedestal and I
think the reason why is because while
games make more money they make more
money from a smaller population because
the film film is so much more purvey
a Marvel film yeah and a billion people
have never played any one game period
except maybe like the Mario franchise in
aggregate over the last 30 years
all the top 10 mobile games right now
yeah that's all I'd want to think about
is how big that market is and how little
I consume it at all
yep and how we don't take it seriously
and when we think about variants
Austin's right like when we when you're
saying video games are not taken
seriously you don't mean mobile games
you because you know that everyone in
the mainstream is playing those you mean
specifically the knee shove kind of
console and PC yeah yeah I mean even
mobile games I think the ones that are
the most successful even even you know
you think of like our $0.10 game like
honor of kings you know it's like
hundreds of millions of players and they
record they'll do big orchestra
recordings that Abby wrote for their
scores you know and hire guys like Hans
Zimmer like they spare no expense on
those but they're also a little bit
flash in the pan
they'll make 50 games
one of them hits and that's the one that
they they sort of ride as long as they
can and then maybe it has a shelf life
of you know a month two months a year
and then people get excited about
whatever X Y Z new game and then they
put all their energy into that it's in a
way and I don't mean this as a to
diminish it but it's like McDonald's
McDonald's has served billions of
burgers like arguably they have fed more
people than almost any entity on the
planet but it's the same that if you're
talking about like your greatest food
experiences of your life you know people
are not typically going to go to that as
their as their I disagree no - have you
ever been really hung over and had some
McNuggets oh my good incredible I'll
have two of your largest portions please
actually I am a weirdo save McDonald's
breakfast apologist III I don't give a
[ __ ] what I come home with man that's
the thing - you buy two hashbrowns on
the side you open it up you put the hash
brown in you close it so good you know
for not being American you sound awfully
American I love yes the ghost of
Tsushima is a direct line to McDonald's
breakfast no but but it's true like the
so I think that the number of people
that see a film I remember one of the
first GDC memories I have I think it was
Clint Hocking or somebody who was giving
like a design rant or something at GDC
12 13 14 years ago and they they made
this point and it still holds true today
even with the continued expansion of the
game industry just simply more people
will see the the the average hit film
yeah especially because of the tale
where there's still there's still the
the remains of the old distribution
model where you'd have a primary market
in theaters and then a secondary market
of maybe 10 years or 15 or in some cases
eternity on
cable TV and blah blah blah where the
the continued resurfacing I mean how
many movies or how often rather is a
better way to phrase it how often do you
like which movie for you is if you're
flipping randomly through a TV even if
it's like in a hotel and you hit upon
fill-in-the-blank film that you're like
I know what I'm doing now for the next
hour I have to see this through to the
end it's just one of those movies I
think everybody has a film that that's
true for right Ilana you may not because
you're like I don't watch movies what is
a movie I mean I like I have movies that
in certain moves I want to watch but
like generally just if I'm bummed out I
just really love that fuss could be do
live action movie is so good I just love
that yeah yeah hero sir yeah yeah yeah
oh he wrote it yeah he didn't direct it
like the Sarah Michelle Gellar yes
that's so you may have directed it but
no goodness because I've seen so few
films I just always want to watch new
stuff I'm really still catching up here
I think he maybe just wrote the
screenplay but it's like when you find
out Jill sweet and wrote Alien
Resurrection you're like oh that's fine
yeah but he also wrote Toy Story Joss
Whedon wrote Toy Story yeah he got
oscar-nominated he's one of several
credited writers to be sure but he is
yeah he is a an Oscar nominee on account
of the screenplay to Toy Story hmm he's
got a few random like I think he also
wrote Titan AE about some movie yes
that's a great movie I genuinely love
being like I want to love this and I
just somehow couldn't but maybe maybe he
was going past my dog blue space
horse-faced bad guy doing my best over
here I was gonna say my contribution to
a list of movies that I feel a very
videogame like would be Kubo and the two
strings of either of you guys seen that
you spent on my list since I saw the
first girlfriend
so I've seen puppets and stuff yeah yeah
I think you have mentioned that before I
love that studio they make animation as
much as I can it's one of them things
I'm very proud
it's one of your best assets my
girlfriend my greatest achievements is
my girlfriends great that movie
specifically I remember seeing it in
theaters and thinking the structure of
this is so videogame II and then it
really feels like there are levels and
then occasionally you'll you'll see the
main character walk into a large open
room and you'll be like this seems like
a boss fight and then the boss comes in
and there's a boss fight and it just in
a way that I don't know why I get this
feeling but I had a weird pride for it
I'm like oh cool you you definitely like
video games and I feel like that fed
into that film and like maybe we'll see
more of that level design structure
because I'm a massive sucker for level
design generally I the difference
between me loving a game and not loving
a game is usually going to be the level
design like that's just the thing that I
tend to pay the most attention to or
remember really distinctly it's just
something that I'd like very intensely
care about like I'll rant about
Dishonored 2 until the day I'm dead
because the level design in that game
god damn so good so when you see a film
that has something like level design
that feels like it's structured it feels
like it's video gave me I still don't
know if that's just iterative a film
doing that in the first place with the
DP or if that is something that
videogames iterated on in an effective
way like I just don't know like as well
right like geography of fight scenes is
such a thing now that I feel like a lot
of I guess possibly bring it back
because of John wick and movies like it
that just kind of pulled that camera
back and gave you a real sense of the
location I wonder if I wonder if those
filmmakers are looking at how video
games stage combat which is all about
like the player being aware of exactly
what's going on and who's around them
and all that stuff and he's actively
kind of putting that in it's maybe maybe
I I think yeah I think it's I think
that's cool you see even more like
what's the Ryan Reynolds NPC comedy
that's coming up
I remember seeing a trailer for that
icon is it called NPC or something yeah
that I have a similar it's like blurry I
remember going where it's Ryan Reynolds
plays and it might
game yeah inebriate he realizes he's a
character in video game and hilarity
presumably ensues that kind of thing
like yeah there's definitely the movie
makers are assuming the audience's video
game literate which is cool which is
great well they've been examples of them
trying to do that that I feel like fails
like pac-man movie I think was the thing
and then there's that movie pixels which
seem to just very much focus on the meme
culture a video game literacy and I
don't think it did particularly well so
I feel like there's still very much a
series of of older execs who recognize
the engagement that video games of
getting online don't recognize how
popular streaming has become or they see
the sales numbers for GTA and they say
we need to tap into that but they still
have absolutely no idea how to do it and
that is really an age thing
well I remember wreck-it Ralph being
quite good yeah was really good actually
but the thing that makes what makes
wreck-it Ralph good is that the the
video game elements to it are kind of
secondary to it as a character piece
yeah which is I think the heart and soul
of what makes I mean truthfully any
narrative experience is that's why you
will end up caring about it you know
like look it in the game side of it are
missing comrade here The Last of Us
solely works on the back of its
profoundly impactful narrative you know
you don't you don't I mean I say that
with all respect to everyone at Naughty
Dog from the bottom to the top like
that's not a game that I see anybody
raving about mechanically or like
gameplay or level design it has a lot I
actually loved the environmental
storytelling of that game I remember
being very I loved exploring and finding
all the traces where you walk into a
room and there's like you know a hand
blood trail leading into a closet or
what you know it's create the sense of
like this is a space that that has
undergone a horrific event and I'm
bearing witness to it as like the dust
has settled and all of that element to
it was fantastic but the reason people
loved it the reason people are excited
about the sequel the reason people are
excited about the HBO show is because it
tells a compelling story really well
all those the crazy thing is so many
games like pac-man is a great example
like the mechanics are just so
beautifully tuned that it just yields
infinite billions of hours of enjoyable
gameplay oh how the hell you turn that
into a film that doesn't feel like it's
just pointing and laughing at it I don't
know I just don't know the answer there
it's probably not possible a mechanic's
driven game I'm not sure could ever
really work I feel like we've we've been
here before I'm having a déjà vu play
watch listen I'm bring up quantum break
and be like if you guys played that game
I feel like we spoken about that we're
almost 15 episodes in or is this episode
15 I think it might be at a certain
point where it's good I don't know
anymore but like that that's an example
of a quantum break being a game where
actually really good gameplay I really
enjoyed the gameplay in that game but
then had the TV segments basically after
each chapter that well live-action and I
personally liked it I liked the way that
I was able to play that I liked playing
through watching my TV episode and then
ending my play session with that it was
like a I had unlocked a reward that I
got to just passively consume maybe it
was because I was playing again on hard
I don't know that it was like a chill
thing to have happen and I liked that
crossover and I know is that a sci-fi TV
series that was supposed to respond to
what you did in game was that define yes
yeah yeah I remember that I remember
working like in a in I was working in a
pitch team games to you when that came
out and everyone was like this could be
the future guys we need to be ready for
this to be how all this it's sort of
fizzled didn't it basically yeah it's
like it was an MMO I think the TV show
from wiper the TV shows actually okay
but like the MMO was kind of great yeah
in a time where there was so many mmo's
right when everyone was chasing that
world Warcraft I just wonder how far out
we are from that partnership existing
more prominently as well because I know
there are a lot of Studios who really do
care about multimedia and about being on
as many platforms as possible I mean EA
does it a lot and is also just very good
at it about you know they have
battlefront too and at the same time
they have a book about
iDEN voseo in the inferno squad
and that's potentially going to be
referenced in mandalorian and and that's
like really because you have the Star
Wars universe but also EA were the ones
who pushed to get that book out like
make sure that happened and that's the
thing that you know all of this content
that you can surround that universe with
is how far offer we have actually having
the the relationship between a video
game series and a movie not feel like
again some exact in a room being like
let's make money off them gamers and
actually feel like a mutually like
respected beneficial relationship
considering how high the player bases or
is that not just possible because to
Austin's point there are so many more
film goers than there are people playing
any one individual game I guess the
closest I can think of a time where I've
seen it done and considered it
successful was the matrix was the matrix
game called the where they like you you
go although you go back now watch
reloaded revolutions which I wouldn't
recommend and and like there are massive
gaps and I have to remind myself all
that was in the game that's why I like I
remember things happening in those
movies that what was the name of the
game lady matrix yeah I know the one
you're talking about but I never played
it either and I can no one literally had
like the Wachowskis shot new footage for
it there were scenes that I keep pulling
up I'm it's a good game incident
Explorer people are gonna roast me for
using internet explorer ax I just want
you to know that the reason I'm using
Internet Explorer to search for matrix
video game rather than another browser
that it's better it's just because this
way there's no search history and I'm
not looking is it
enter the matrix that's the one into the
matrix that was running alongside that
of the first two films with full motion
Clips filmed at the same time is
reloaded revealing extra parts of the
story no way I didn't so you see the
character you played was Niobe who's in
the movies played by Jada pinkett-smith
yeah yeah so the character you'll yeah
that's the character you're playing in
the game so you'll kind of duck she
ducks in and out the movies a lot and
those away you're going and playing the
level so as like the exact right age to
be obsessed with the matrix like during
has the optical run and the other matrix
into the matrix and all that stuff like
for me that was amazing I was like oh I
I know more than everyone around me but
it does play into the Austin point of
like the movies couldn't
- you hadn't played the game most people
wouldn't have done you know as the the
also the creative process is so
different like going back to that the
transmedia thing the sci-fi defiant
defiance yes oh like the thing that is
so intrinsically impossible about that
is that the the lead time to create a
season of television versus the
continuous unrolling of MMO like just
even look here's my pivot so Bear
McCreary did the music for defiance but
he also did the music on agents of
shield and look at their struggle to
just keep pace with the rest of the MCU
like they just full-on gave up by at
some point because they even said
publicly you know their big season
finale timed precisely with the finale
of infinity war and and the two just
don't they just don't overlap in fact so
much so that you're like shouldn't they
be aware of this global catastrophe
going on just down the road and they the
the ABC execs and the Marvel TV folks
were like yeah you know basically are
shifting production schedule and they're
shifting production schedule made
keeping our writers sort of in tandem
with each other basically impossibility
so we just kind of have to do our own
thing like they always tried to pay
lip-service I remember after it was
early in the show when Winter Soldier
came out and so like the episode begins
with them saying you know Coulson
walking and going look I know we've all
had a really rough week or whatever and
like referencing IO remember that whole
a coup d'etat where helicarriers try to
ruin everything about life on earth like
that sucked but it's a new day let's
move on with our lives like that was
about the closest they were able ever
able to get to having interconnectivity
and that's something that's not
player-driven
like that's just TV schedule versus fill
yes schedule like just the production
cycles for these different formats are
so vastly different I'm the production
like the process as well again I'm sorry
I keep bringing back John Waite but that
is really relevance this yeah because
you're describing like it the just look
like the nature of iteration like Anisa
these
like the people on the film side is
super smart they know their stuff but
having to explain to like them how
iteration works that like we make it and
then we remake it and we tweak and we
fiddle with it we change it rather than
that like this is the moment we set the
script in stone this is how we do this
and then lining that up with they were
making the third movie while we were
making the game and like getting access
to that script going over literally
flying to LA to read the script and and
and doing that process and then and then
going into the Edit process with them
and like all of those overlaps it just
it's a lot of work like it's at
maintaining that kind of connectivity
and that that because we were we were
you know we were lucky in that we were
deliberately making something that was
like a prequel to a prequel yeah we were
way we new narrative ly we didn't have
to worry too much if you have a motion
about being more current or was it just
from the jump you didn't want to do it
it was my pitch to them was I actually
pitched it to them as the
self-destructing universe I was like the
one of the biggest strengths of John
wick is that it's mythic and that
there's ambiguity about all the stories
but also that your protagonist literally
kills everyone may encounter so you
could literally with John wick you could
go and make this kind of the John wick
hex universe kind of self destructs it
kind of it's a bunch of interesting
character clothes is sort of wig it's
kind of a closed loop
yeah and that and that made things
easier but that was the main reason I
pitched it to them as that way was just
because of exactly the problems you're
describing it's just like if we had made
it the you know a specific character
it's it's just and this is I'll step
away from John wait but like movies
remove characters there are characters
who are like massively important in a
film and then when they get to the edit
suite they're like oh we need to just
cut this character there happens all the
time
and we here have actor friends who are
who I I have a friend who was like the
main bad guy in one of those like like I
think it was London has fallen but you
know that franchise with Gerard Butler
of the like Secret Service superhero I
think it was London has fallen I have an
actor friend who was like basically the
main bad guy but he was sort of
answering to his father
the uber bad guy behind the bad guy and
then in the Edit they recut the film so
heavily that my friend basically is not
in the movie anymore and the father
figure has kind of assumed the role
the Edit as the main villain and it's
one of those I'm not sure you're making
the game if you imagine if you were
making the game where your buddy was
like an intrinsic part of the plot
suddenly because the filmmakers they
shouldn't have to compromise their
vision to facilitate your video game and
likewise if you're a video game to UMS
over by those writer so it's a lot of
trust and long reliance I think I think
what gets easier is as a franchise
exists certain things I never locked in
but there's enough like of a Bible that
you can like with Star Wars like there
are unmovable points and characters you
can rely on being a certain place at
certain time so you can in Star Wars I
think it's probably easier to do
something like ye aidid and kind of a
kind of character who's in this kind of
this new way even with John wick that
was only a couple of movies at that
point there was enough established law
and world building that we knew the
things that they weren't going to change
in the next movie but if you try to
build something like specifically from
the ground up we're alongside a movie
that's really tricky I think you
probably be better off waiting until one
of the things have matured like if you
like if you imagine like well I mean the
last of us TV show is sort of that right
but then I have this thing where and I
don't know but they're probably they're
presumably they're just gonna adapt the
right which I just don't get like I
don't know maybe I should think about it
more broadly and in my head my reaction
of that being announced a lot of people
realize it feels so we'd have this
conversation without Troy here but if
people were very excited but I was just
like I have already played that game and
I love that game and that game does such
an incredible job of selling you those
two characters in their relationship why
do I want to watch something else that
just does the same thing I was like oh
if you didn't parallel is it like all
the characters in that way give me the
same flaws origin story or something but
I'm not actually okay that's interested
but I think yeah I think it is a
straight add up to I mean obviously Troy
would know but I I that was my
impression as well that it is Joel and
Ellie there eighty is the Last of Us of
the game of the show yeah huh which to
me just seems like such an odd thing to
do but I guess well look at The Witcher
on Netflix like say in the books that's
true they're not adapting the game
direct
no so that still feels very different
not that people don't know most game
adaptations seem to be just a mess but
but with the loss of us like is that
maybe I need to think about it you know
gods - well this is an incredible story
that I really love what about people who
don't play video games or don't want to
play a game like that that is pretty
scary and pretty intense they should
still get to experience that story in
theory so I kind of don't know where I
land on that but in terms there's
potential for way more people to
experience it yeah propose a point a
minute ago like it could be ten times
the audience size but yeah actually I
don't want people to miss out on that
story because it's frankly really good
but it's definitely a situation of you
know if if all we're doing when it comes
to having a lot of videogame properties
be made into movies - just adaptations I
don't feel like that strengthens either
medium I do feel like there are examples
like John wick or like what it sounds
like you described with the matrix Mike
where video games enhance films video
games do that the other way around like
I feel like John wick existing or hex
existing in theory adds extra content to
enhance that universe but I don't feel
like a very generous of you and I would
know I would definitely not necessarily
be but we benefited I think it was a
bi-directional thing we benefited from
them like in terms of like we we we had
some rules about a world we had some
mechanics we could build on because of
you know the audience knows how to play
or get arguably the movies of a tutorial
for our game so we definitely we
actually had that in play testing I
again
Dasia although I feel like maybe I've
said this on the show before but late
and in my testing we genuinely saw the
people who knew the movies were better
at the game
which was interesting though because
that demonstrates that clearly the game
was dependent on awareness how if you
don't mind me asking or if you're
allowed to talk about it how did that
game come about from the the pitch
stages I feel like we probably spoke
about this with the panel but I mean
like if you can talk about secret lost
first episode of zero incriminating
photos of several people Lionsgate I was
it was a body they could see you or did
you go to them they came to me
rubbing though to be clear they came to
me and I think probably a lot of other
people shot and said like what would you
what would you do with John where can I
pitch them on I don't because the
obvious answer is the third person
shooter right like that's the that's the
clean straightforward thing but for me
the big problem with the third person
shooter is you're clumsy as a player
like I'm clumsy when I play a third
person shooter I'm circle strafing and I
don't play third-person shooters the way
John wick fights in the movie I didn't
wanna do that so I pitched the me I
pitch in the strategy game cuz I figured
like that would give you the time to
like figure it out and basically just
pitch them that made a little prototype
with you know classic kind of gray box
ugly thing and flew to LA and demoed
that and got you know and now and then
it's the Hollywood Bing which is just
constant pitching so demonstrated to the
initial people then to the other people
and just kept broadening out until
you're in the room with the actual like
with Chad basically the director and
Basle the exec producer like playing
well not playing looking at me play and
kind of giving that so yeah it was very
weird very weird they came to me though
it was it was it was nice but why I
think it came from was it was a
friendship basically is is been a news
it was collusion and guarded it was
collusion behind closed doors clusion
nepotism I'm but but someone who's a
producer who I've gone on with he
produced up no man's sky and used a
bunch of different cool self and a
couple of my games so I think when so he
was approached to kind of try and
produce a John wick game and I think I
was one of the people on his list of
like I wonder what that guy would do and
so so I benefit from that as well so
definitely not just me being the best
opportunity that's how how industries
work really but to your point of like a
third person shooter potentially making
you clumsy oh do stupid stuff that John
wick would not necessarily do I do think
that's also a really interesting part of
IPs like I know I don't even know if
this is a public or not sometimes I
forget like if things have just been
told to me that's the goal each episode
awesome night had a rebrand towards the
end of development of that game because
the
akhom night character spoiler if you
haven't played it really is just Red
Hood but they really didn't want players
to know more than Batman because I think
WB had an issue with the idea that
Batman would be seen as stupid and the
audience would all know that that was
Red Hood it seemed very obvious to me
anyway like when you know if you if you
know anything about Red Hood you know
what's happening in that through-line
but I feel like that's a an IP
protection thing that video games do
have to be considerate always like if
you're playing a game when you have
Batman that Detective has to be smarter
than you you cannot know something he
doesn't know if you have a game where
you're playing John wick John wick has
to be very calculate and very good at
what he does or he's not John wick and
these two things that are supposed to
line up like Batman's probably the most
successful multimedia franchise that I
can think of probably ever it's on
everything and successful at virtually
all of them like God since the sixties
that's the crazy thing and they do that
by having this this cohesiveness with
characters that you in any of those
formats short Batman gets really goofy
and it's shock repellent and he went
down the whole nipple journey that's all
happened but you still know what Batman
is you know he's the world's greatest
detective and that still has to be true
in Arkham Knight and I always found that
really interesting like the idea that
they will they just lost minute had the
realization that all the players are
gonna know what this is the players
can't know more than Batman or the whole
of Batman is ruined and that's gonna be
especially if we're talking about like a
movie video game crossover is just such
a complicated thing to retain IP that I
feel like at some points which it
doesn't sound like it was really the
case with John wick it's just more
complicated than people want to bother
with yeah
and that's so then it's a fair thing
right there's lots of developers who
don't do IP based stuff and is Joe does
yeah challenging on that level but it's
collaboration right and ultimately I
think as well it depends on the
collaboration it depends on what the IP
is like with John wick it was pretty
loose in terms of like you know they
respected me to kind of trust watch but
as far as I know I never pitched them
like a terrible idea so I kind of we
never had like an argument like that or
a misunderstanding of like John wick
can't do that I think that was partially
because we were making good choices but
also I think they they're a bit there
earlier in the franchise building so
they were accepting of that self whereas
I've worked on like I remember like
years and years ago working on like
Nickelodeon stuff and sponge
there's hundreds of pages of like this
is spongebob this is how spongebob looks
this is this is this kind of situation
SpongeBob's views on things how does how
does spongebob solve a problem you know
and the yeah but like seriously in some
cases like it goes that far like this is
the political alignment of this cartoon
character but like that's but that's in
a way I think that's really good as well
like it's it's it can be very limiting
and constraining but at the same time
like as a game designer like that's
that's interesting to know the rules
rule sets are really important to games
and I think knowing where you stand it
means that design don't have that much
choice it sways yeah yeah that's I think
that can be really empowering and really
cool I know the other thing as well is
you can kind of piggyback on the
learning some like spongebob I remember
one of the coolest this is so nerdy but
it's it's genuinely is one of the
coolest days I ever had at work was me
and a guy called dad's Watford who was
concept artists I was working with Aaron
as has since now does all the concept on
before games and we've worked together
for years now but me and him was out
there kind of young baby us and we've
been given some spongebob stuff to work
on and we've gotten their their design
Bible and we realized we were looking
through and we realized that on
Nickelodeon there are 15 colors
full-stop 15 hues there is a yellow
there is a Nickelodeon yellow who's a
Nickelodeon green there is a Nickelodeon
blue there's precisely defined that is
the Nickelodeon blue and the reason they
do it is because they can put any
Nickelodeon character on a billboard
next to any other Nickelodeon character
and those colors are gonna harmonize and
look good and I remember me and me and
dads just nerding out over this like the
wheat like we'd seen through like we'd
seen through the matrix we'd seen like
hold the stay yellow on Sponge Bob is
the exact same yellow that is the bowtie
on this you know that probably also you
know what the secondary effective that
probably also is is it's not just that
you could see two different Nickelodeon
characters on a billboard and they would
harmonize but if you saw a Nickelodeon
billboard and like a John wick billboard
or Ori or like a Pixar
billboard maybe a better comparison you
you don't you you don't even have to
actually look at it to if you've been
around enough and had that kind of
ambient exposure I bet that you would
intuitively know it's pick out that it's
a Nickelodeon just in peripheral vision
almost and that's what the franchises
can do is they can kind of teach you all
of this stuff they presumably
Nickelodeon spent millions working that
out
I know it's simple likes evening like in
after you after you hear about you're
like I could come up with a pallet
fifteen colors that's no problem but I
bet they spend a lot of money and time
figuring that stuff out for the reasons
you say Austin and likewise like with
John wick they have the best martial
artists in the world developing these
fight styles and these approaches to
stun choreography and I just get to walk
in at the last stage of that and go yell
have that and it's kind of is this
really interesting kind of building on
the shoulders of giants aspect of all of
this stuff same with that man right like
crucially with that man um
the goofy was the original Batman and
then you have kind of the late eighties
you have kind of your Dark Knight kind
of era where everything goes very grim
dark and then you have kind of things
lighten up and darken up and and shift
and change but everyone's building on
what went before and that's what's
interesting Dark Knight isn't as good if
Adam West's silly Batman never existed
that's true unlike wise on and on the
Arkham games rely on you having seen the
Batman movies specific to the Justice
League movie presumes that you know Ben
Affleck's backstory is every Batman
story by right is that there's just some
very interesting kind of franchises
billed and there's a really interesting
kind of different kind of storytelling
and different kind of set of
expectations you can work with and have
really right back to your point that's
also true of video games going the other
way potentially like the sonic movie I
arguably cared more about that character
because I I know sonic because I've
played sonic not the world's best movie
but like I connected with it in a way
that I wouldn't have done with like
generic children's animated movie number
26 Sonic's been a part of your life for
a really long time yeah yeah it carries
over it means something you know they
can do jokes which rely on those
expectations they can do story beats
that rely on
there's really not relationship you know
something that that since you're
bringing it back I realized the thought
occurred to me I didn't want to
interrupt earlier and then I and then it
vanished was just that on that subject
of the the initial question of games
potentially informing any other media
but particularly film and to the extent
that that's possible to the extent that
it makes sense to the extent it's even a
good idea a thought occurred to me was
it was that all media all art all
creative acts all all in like literally
you can balloon this to as big a
category as you want
everything is always on some level a
reflection of the tools that is are used
to make it right like if you and the
medium in which you're working as a
byproduct of that tool like if I if I
have a fork and a knife and wax to make
a sculpture with I'm gonna make a
different sculpture fundamentally even
if I'm trying to make the same thing as
if I have a blowtorch and like scrap
metal right like to do a different kind
of sculpture with alright how violent
both of those process is well yes
exactly that way yeah exactly in that
way maybe it's just a reflection of me
more than but at some point is like and
and that's where you see video game
tools like perfect took apropos our
conversation last week of the Unreal
demo where like the things that the
Unreal Engine can do well it are is
naturally going to yield games that lean
into that feature set and it's not that
these games are imitating each other and
so I think that as we're prior to today
a lot of the disconnect between film and
game is just wildly different sets of
tools and even if you had the most
die-hard filmmaker gamer like a Duncan
Jones you mentioned they're just using
really different tools to make their
film that I think interestingly might be
on the cusp of changing because the
thought that occurred to me was I'm
friends with this director Wes ball who
was famously recently
shared online his his sort of pitch real
for the adaptation of the mouse guard
that he was making that got scrapped by
Disney as part of the Fox acquisition he
had previously directed all of the Maze
Runner films and REM saying this you
know and and the so he did this previz
in unreal hundred afore and he learned
how to do it himself he comes from a
visual effects background so his films
always like if you watch those Maze
Runner movies I mean they're they're
they're young adult sort of Hunger Games
type things but the thing that his work
always for sure has across the board is
this a striking visual sense especially
beyond what the budget would seemingly
have have been able to achieve because
he's a very very visually gifted guy and
when he watched this mass card previous
and unreal the only difference between
it and a video game was that his didn't
have to be rendered in real time so he
because the previous of this thing is
amazing you're like this is this is not
the actual movie and he's like oh no no
no look at that you know the hair
particle there is no good and that light
bounces off the water weird and he has
all these very nitpicky issues with it
but because it's this is not the real
thing but I remember thinking I wonder
what the implications for filmmaking
would be if they're using video game
tools to make their film because that's
gonna have the same effect as when video
game companies are all using the same
tools they're gonna start leaning into
the things that it does really well and
all these discussions of level design
and character design and character
animation all the different ways that
games have optimized the use of that or
the creation of that for themselves may
just roll straight into film and
suddenly films are starting to feel very
video gaming and it's not really an
aspiration it's just literally the tools
are so convenient and so fast and so
iterative did they just start using them
see I think it was the blacklist TV show
and it's finale and because they had not
finished shooting completely over Hubble
they had to have some animated bits
basically and I go cool it's very
strange
this one isn't the one I'm referring to
it might not be the blacklist I might be
wrong about the show but it's very much
like an animated it looks like the
tell-tale engine it's very we
it and the thought that like they
basically looked like it looks like they
put a video game cutscene into that show
to add the final season and I keep
thinking what a the older people who
don't know what video games are who is
seeing this going to think of this weird
final season they've gotten but in
theory us and you're right like
especially in in a situation like kovat
having I think more accessibility or
just a transfer of skills for someone
who could use an engine who could if
need be fix something like that or add
something into a film later using the
techniques of unreal doesn't seem like
that's that far off or that unlikely
especially because we have to use it
right now people are doing that right on
the Amanda look Mandalorian does it all
over the shop already right and that was
I think you're right Austin no I think
that's gonna inform the the visual
language like Mandalorian the specific
stuff they use it for is the kind of
mid-range desert II environment not much
linking the foreground and background I
make they do use it there's a far seem
they use it for which is incredible but
like generally they're using it in kind
of limited way and that prepare for a
lot of scenes where characters a
relatively stationary in front of mid to
far distance backgrounds not having any
back and forth interaction with those
environment I think backgrounds with
that extras I haven't watched the behind
the scenes from Illinois and I really
should what pretty good they've done
like a standalone documentary called um
gallery which is Suraj leads you'd like
it's got a lot of the UH the showrunner
from chlorine too and I think that's
like a thing that I will always love
about Stahl was how much I've said this
a million times before just pushed the
medium forwards and I love that it's
continuing to do so with Mandalorian
with this entirely new way of shooting
that I guess is kind of video game II it
is a background that exists on a wall
that you've put a character into have
you seen have you seen the Favreau stuff
on have you seen the the Disney the new
Lion King they did have you seen all the
stuff about now they made that basically
in real time so all of the Disney Lion
King then you get the new Lion King
Favreau is so easy mister his
they really also they shot it so they
what they did was they basically they
they essentially to use Austin's mates
thing as an example they shot they shot
in you know I think it wasn't unreal
they basically so a scene of I know
Simba walking across the screen right
what they would do is they they made
them they made a rough version animation
put it in engine and then they like
mocap essentially cameras so they had
like cameramen who were like experienced
live in nature photographers or like
filmmakers actually like with these
virtual cameras following this this
action in a VR environment they were
then record the camera and and and then
and then that camera would then be used
in their in the real thing and once
you've had that point it's so clear yeah
they did sort of Pride Rock shot so in
the opening of lion king circle of life
where you have like that big high up
camera shot of the Pride Rock with
Rafiki holding up Simba and that's me
holding ups in of course you do Star
Wars bar yeah we need a second weekend
at Sponge Bob
so they shot that they they put mocap on
a drone and they shot it as a miniature
in a virtual miniature essentially so
they got so they could simulate what a
helicopter shot might look like in that
environment that's a movie it looks so
they and that's and you genuinely like
The Lion King I think the new Lion King
movies you know got its imperfections
but the making off stuff is so
fascinating mmm and and predate a lot
like prefigures you can see how jon
favreau did that got some ideas and then
when I made Mandalorian and there you
can see kind of I think what
Mandalorians done is just super exciting
in general the way that that technology
works is also like really helpful for a
situation like ovid where people can't
be around each other because you can
have a really limited amount of people
actually physically on that stage at any
given time because the background can
all be edited or pieced together like
copy pasted humans together basically
which is very weird landscape and you
know I've seen conversations about what
that means for people who make that
money as full-time extras because in
theory they would not have as many days
on set because they don't need to be
there when it's true
the main actors are recording so there's
a bunch of like issues there with them
more digital things are getting but it's
it's it's crazy cool stuff and I always
find it fascinating um like Detroit
become human or I think most of Quantic
schemes do it but they they specifically
hired a DP who had only ever worked in
film for Detroit become human to make
sure that you know shots have a certain
amount of green or a certain tone or for
Clara I think her name is she's very
much like aggressively framed as being
small and they're you often see sort of
I don't know how to describe literally
just frames around her so that she seems
very oppressed in the environments which
is old techniques that have come from
film directly because you're making a
game that is very much cinematic and
focused on being like film and I guess
that that was really my leading question
that I wanted to ask you guys about
today was you know when do we see films
that and we have raised a few examples
that become like games cuz I for
whatever reason wants that like like I
like when you say like games you mean
like interactive is that like
Bandersnatch in what's sure I think you
might have worked on it Austin what's
the the Erica yes that way right that's
live-action
there it is but in I've had to repeat
this line a million times air whereas
Bandersnatch is very much an interactive
film basically erica is a filmed game
erica is very gamey it has it is it is
not token interaction slapped on to
something that was produced like a film
it was conceived of as a game from day
one okay just to just to make me play so
if it reminds me of um it reminds me of
the x-files FMV game from years ago
which if they not even know that existed
I thought I knew the FMV well pretty
deep and that was very much like what
you're describing him and that was a
point-and-click adventure game that
happened to also use video footage like
it felt it felt very gamy in a way that
you're absolutely right the Netflix
stuff doesn't quite have that same vibe
so again relating to tools partly be
it's dependent on what the Netflix isn't
overly confidential information but I
remember Jack language saying that they
had conversations or they explored or
maybe even just contemplated the notion
of collaborating with Netflix because
Bandersnatch came out right when we were
just about finished with Erica yeah and
no one knew it was coming and I remember
he went and looked at and he was like
their tech couldn't possibly support
what we need it to like they're all of
your interactions and stuff no no I mean
it's just yeah like we're full we're
taking advantage of even a mobile game
is tricky because the file size to
download all this high-res footage
it's just that problem alone is and to
stream it would be essentially next to
impossible because there's there's
interactions every few seconds that just
cut immediately based on what you are
choosing why Sam always makes his games
about webcam exactly lower resolution
he's super smart well he also you know
he says explicitly his goal is to not be
cinematic that's like explicitly part of
the agenda that's part of what makes
them genius I [ __ ] love his game yes
so much and Sam Farrar for our sorry
were slightly up to Sam Barlow telling
lies and and her story I mean those are
also really good examples of film games
they blur a line between which of those
two things that they they are and I mean
I haven't played Eric I really feel like
I should I'm so interested in that in
that concept especially if you say
there's interactions every few seconds I
didn't expect that like that's that's
really cool I should definitely give it
a try
I imagine the the school is pretty good
so well I don't I don't know if this is
good but yeah Mike's probably know what
would make it better you know what make
it better literally any other composer
if it had been the hotline Miami so many
of those songs just existed beforehand
yeah Jack really should have just
licensed hotline Miami it's just it's
just a soundtrack you want to listen to
his game again
right now Austin you're very good at
what you do just in case you didn't know
and nobody's told you recently you're
very good at what don't you you're very
good at what you do is this like the
parking validation taken to its extreme
here no it's just genuine I head out the
door that's very that's very kind of you
I would not presume to compete with
hotline Miami though you I will say I
don't I don't know if I can endorse the
quality of Erica but I will say it was
the most technically challenging score
I've ever written far in a way because
of how extremely interactive it had to
be because of the fact that you make
meaningful choices constantly like and
because it's a film the level of nuance
that you pick up as a player is so much
greater than even the highest level
mocap currently offers because it's like
you say one line and a character's
eyebrows shifts in response and it's
like if I ignore that musically I'm
actually ignoring the storytelling
because that eyebrow raised was the
storytelling and aside from obviously
very carefully created cinematics in a
game of the level of fidelity of like
The Last of Us you just don't have that
like in a dialogue scene you take a Mass
Effect game there will be or Dragon Age
or something there's a [ __ ] ton of
dialogue but you don't have that line
reaction pause reaction like all that
goes into crafting a dialogue scene of a
film because it's just 10 times more or
a hundred times more content you don't
get that extreme level you might you
might get the actors trying to bring
that from a voice performance but all
the other elements in the visual nature
of it is is largely like oh really kind
of only la know ah that really has ever
done that that that extensively when you
do have to pay attention to the nuance
of every single facial expression and
it's and it's like that's a game
mechanic yeah yeah but that was also
like are they lying can you can you
catch the criminal and yeah and I found
you that was exactly I failed every time
because I was like I think they're
having a stroke she's definitely lying
face was weird as hell no she wasn't I
was like yeah I was like that she's
wants me to think she said well actually
it's like no yeah
so that Eric Koston like what did you do
dude is it just did you just the music
and exhaling regular music it it's
actually it's the music well so little
plug for my youtube channel I actually
have a video on my youtube channel
that's a 10 or 11 minute video called
anatomy of a scene and it's a single
two-minute scene where I did a capture
playing through the scene and I and I
narrate over top of it and we have a
visual map going by showing you the way
the score is in constant motion where
it's like okay if I click on this it's
going to bring in a violin but then
immediately as character comes in so I
have to bring in a cello doing this and
so I walk through and then it rewinds
after a few minutes it says now what if
I had done this one thing differently
and it plays through the scene and it
shows that entirely different content
musically and visually in gameplay in
every way in every sense shows up as a
result and so it took like a month to
make this one video just to kind of
analyze how insane we had to get because
you know at the start I didn't think it
had to be that complicated but then Jack
would say well we'll wait a minute but
the character just brought up this and
that's kind of a hint to this thing
later where the the we bring up the
mother and all that I realized yeah
you're right that's a pretty important
piece of foreshadow I can't ignore that
but to put the kick the player might not
choose that line of dialogue so we have
to have this optional ability to pivot
into a bit of very narrative sense and
it's like every few seconds there was a
discussion like that so it's really it's
an at it's a normal amount of score in
terms of like how much I'm normally
tasked to do you know it's around maybe
80 minutes of music and just shy of an
hour and a half which is not that much I
mean most games tend to round out around
an hour unless they're inordinately
large games but like that's just kind of
a number that seems to be reasonably
typical it's to the extent that it's
remotely possible to generalize this one
the key is that it's like an hour
consisted of a million tiny Lego blocks
interest that all have to figure it all
these different combinations for
reassembly and a constant moving target
sort of way it's so cool because all
breaking aspects is how invisible that's
what I was gonna say is like the amount
of stuff like that that goes into making
a video game like you know you making
that part of that game that no
nobody has any idea about and how
complicated that by design yeah no I
mean it should feel like it should feel
like wow they're playing and this is
true of journey or even Assassin's Creed
or anything else my goal is to feel like
they are playing but if we just if they
just if they could somehow just kind of
close their eyes and keep playing they
wouldn't be able to tell the difference
between I'm watching a movie and I'm
playing a game meaning you don't pick up
on the game reacting to the mechanics it
just feels like I know what you're gonna
do and I want to give you your emotional
support of your experience I want the
music to know ah I walked through the
door and the music swelled right when I
did but it's as if it was locked in time
and always meant to be that way you know
my little way of describing it is a
twitch streamer two different twitch
streamers if you were to just watch them
as a film like the gameplay of a stream
as a film it should feel as tightly
scored as if it was a film but yet the
two different streamers would have two
different film scores that's sort of my
goal with every project it's so cool um
different games lend itself to that
different ways you know obviously like
John wick Hex's has a very different set
of systems driving it and so it's it's
gonna succeed or not in along different
sort of parameters I guess yeah just
just so many things about video games
that are so kated to making sure players
have good experiences that we just don't
even notice in the way that like with
you know the conversation about film
that we notice all of it but like you
know in in games people have control of
a 360 degree camera if you need to tell
a story well you need to have them look
at a specific thing there is the
decision of do you have to take away the
control of the camera at that point or
do you have to somehow have you know use
of lines to direct people's eyesight in
a certain way like a lot of it's kind of
manipulation but in a lot of ways to
make sure that that experience is the
best for that player and then or you
just turn them loose I mean we talked
about that all the time right the the
ludonarrative dissonance like like
dialogue scenes in half-life 2 where you
can just wander around and be jumping up
and down and banging your crowbar
against the wall while they're having
like intimate dialogue and they just
they just ignore you and just this past
week I've played
finally plagues tale which I really
liked actually I was really that strong
choice of game right now wasn't it yeah
actually it was it was it was interview
prep because I was interviewing the
composer on the on the game major
notebook podcast and I had never played
a game he scored is the only composer I
think I could possibly name that that's
true for among my friends and colleagues
where I somehow literally have never
played a game of his and I thought well
that's that's just wrong especially cuz
I think his music is fantastic and so I
went that was I played through little
bits of five four or five different
games of his but that one after the
interview I was like I actually feel
that I have to go finish that game I
really was liking how long is it and I
might play it like next week I've been
thinking about it it's not nine hours I
think was do you love it love to hear it
it's got I would love to get your take
on it because there are things that I
love about it and then there were things
that I was very mixed you did you play
Mike I've known ya know again one that's
on the backlog but right now don't as a
side no get to it the voice acting in it
it's one of those games that hinges on
the dynamic between two characters we
it's a sister and a brother and the
little boy the voice acting of the
little boy was so good that I was like
god I care about this kid and it's so
much on the back of like they just do
such a good job of you're in this
horrendous environment of this plague
just ravishing everything and these
terrifying rats everywhere and then the
little boy will come across like a dead
cow and be like is he sleeping and just
says the most innocent thing in the most
sort of dark moment and it's just so
[ __ ] effective but but the reason I
bring it up is because there are a few
moments where they had a choice of do we
go the half-life route or do we just
like lock the camera in because there's
a few moments where they have cutscenes
but then there's others where there will
be an extended dialogue exchange not in
a cutscene and they actually they
actually let your character move within
a very narrow band of space but you
cannot walk away from the scene entirely
because normally I'm all about the
immersion but in this one instance I
just felt like exploring the room during
the dialogue scene and it wouldn't let
me and I thought you know interesting
choice like you're restricting the
players agency because in this moment
the story
there's more and it's like yeah I don't
have I don't know if that's for better
or worse a hard decision to make I think
yeah oh yeah it's that's what games are
is essentially like a million rocks it's
why every game developer like the most
insulting thing you can say to a game
developer is that they're lazy yeah
because they're you spend your whole
life making loads of decisions that no
one will ever care yeah all that will be
so hidden away because if you do them
right if you make decisions it's so
invisible before we end I wanted to ask
you because you hit on something earlier
that I genuinely hadn't ever thought of
in quite those terms and I want to put
both of you a question to both of you
and Troy just doesn't get to answer this
question off the dock yeah I miss Troy
oh not me to hell with him mrs. hare but
his head was good right his head was
good but that's just a lie you brought
up when you were talking about Arkham
and needing to not be smarter than
Batman that actually was a pretty
revelatory because I realized that
really is a massive differentiation
between film and games that I'd never
thought of quite so directly that that
because because I thought immediately of
Hitchcock so much of Hitchcock's
intention design is about you as an
audience member being ahead of the
character he loved creating scenes like
there's one of my favorites is from from
his TV show from Alfred Hitchcock
Presents I think that's what it was
called where there was a scene of
imagine a hallway where you can you can
both see me where the camera like the
camera you are the camera and there's a
there's a hallway like a lobby of a bank
and imagine you know they have like a
cubical wall that are actually just a
full-on wall that that stops in the
lobby in the center of the frame so
there's this wall that you can see on
edge that moves away from the camera and
on one side is a janitor who's mopping a
floor and on the other side is a guy
who's going desk by desk stealing or
trying to break into a safe or something
and they they both both of these kind of
hallways spill into a central lobby and
they're very
gradually over the course of like a five
minute shot making their way towards
your POV as a viewer and in towards each
other unbeknownst to each other and it's
just a single static shot for like five
minutes where you sit there completely
on edge and such typical clock
brilliance where they they're
unawareness of each other is precisely
why the scene is amazing and what you're
saying is that especially in this
archetypal hero kind of way if the
player is ahead of their own character
they immediately will shut out or
they'll think oh this is so stupid like
just it's right in front of you you
idiot I know it you should know it and
it's like the kind of cognitive ding I
think if it's you know horror films a
lot of the tension often comes from you
having to be for something but you know
horror game you have to be experiencing
exactly what the character is
experiencing at the same right I got so
then my question oh sorry go ahead
I know you got well my question then is
to you guys can you imagine a game in
which that Hitchcock idea would work
where your character yeah your player
character you are ahead of them and that
is the excitement is that a thought
experiment that yields something to you
because I can't think of you made me
realize I can't think of a game where if
I'm supposed to be Batman I can I can be
in that moment like a better Batman than
my player Batman and it's doesn't yield
anything other than a disappointing game
but is that in your mind could you
imagine that look now that you've like
floated the idea I want to see what that
looks like and how to make it work right
but I don't know that it exists really
at all like no it's tricky it's also
tricky to do the opposite the hyper
competent character because we like when
we did on some surface circular we went
to a detective game it's really hard to
detective fiction because you know
Sherlock Holmes his cloud is so much
cleverer than you that the fun of a
Sherlock Holmes story is is you catching
up with him right yeah exactly so you
from that side it's also really
challenging no I don't it's a tough one
I don't know I don't know iconic man
example except I guess you can make an
argument that like strategy games or
like stealth games like you can see
round corners of the plate but but even
that's like solid snake has awareness
like he's you're you're simulating
something that he already knows it's not
you don't feel when Joel does his vision
mode where he can see through walls you
think Joel also knows the information so
it's not the same thing that's right so
yeah I can't think of a common example
they'd be really hard to do without it
be incredibly frustrating to the player
because because that's sweet frustration
of a Hitchcock thriller that's the
pleasure right like rope is amazing yeah
have you seen you must have seen rope if
you're a Hitchcock fan like the wave of
that play you don't know that I have oh
go see rope it's one shot well it's not
one shot because at the time film I
think I think of film connoisseurs like
20 minutes also so there's it's a 100 or
less than that actually because modern
they have to keep they keep zooming into
objects and then pulling out but it's
basically a Towanda hat yeah and it's a
similar setup in a Hitchcock way of like
there's a box in the middle of the room
and you know what's in the box but
knowing the characters do well two of
the gates do but the others don't right
now it's rope if you haven't yeah it's
really good I'm but I don't know how you
do again without being yeah either
frustrating or you having to be in the
Hitchcock role yeah if it was you
knowing Raven the player character and
[ __ ] mechanic Adam that sounds very
exciting to me but I doubt that's it but
that's different yeah it's like I guess
if it was a game like remember lemmings
like that's one where the character it's
not but that's the thing you are not the
lemmings that's your like god no you're
gold right yeah yeah yeah and that's and
that's where that's where it's different
that's like because you you you know
creating a path for a character to
autopilot through that's kind of the
closest thing to being the being
Hitchcock or being the director or the
audience but that's very different
because you're not projecting yourself
onto the character at that point I
wonder if you could do it I wonder if
you could do it in a weird way with like
an empathetic empathetic third party
character so if imagine like a game
where you're looking through like a
security camera I feel like this might
have been done I feel like there was a
ps2 game I had a moment like this and
someone in the comments will main that
um imagine again where you're looking
through like a CCTV camera and you can
see a character in the room and
something Bad's coming for that
character your Janus is about to come
and couch they did that in the recent
duty modern warfare actually there's a
whole level Oh way you can give like
directions girl trying to escape the
embassy and you're looking at right
through the security camera that's kind
of it right fantastic stuff with
security cameras and like infiltrating
buildings just by hacking the cameras
like this cool stuff with that so but
yeah but the Call of Duty example you're
right that's why I'm ripping off but I
think it was there's also other games
but yeah that that's really that's like
just the new modern warfare I mean the
the one that just came out yeah I know
the one you may know I know the one you
mean I've totally ripped that off it's
not an original brilliant idea but like
that that sort of Chiefs are you talking
about right because you know more than
the protagonist in the scene the
difference is that you are in danger the
difference is that your character is the
person looking at the camera and talking
to the girl do you feel no the same
amount that your protagonist actually
knows not even be possible like how can
the camera yeah I mean like I don't know
that it's yeah yeah a really interesting
question because I think it comes down
to the core of like what is satisfying
about video games which is that level of
engagement of what keeps you playing
often is a sense of discovery alongside
the protagonists because you're
effectively the same person like I just
I don't I don't know that it would that
very intrinsically film horror film
especially I feel like well thriller
film feeling is is possible to have in a
video game I just don't I don't you
could be pretentious and say that the
old Resident Evil's do it if you're
white B and if you want I'm talking like
super pretension there now you could go
and cause of the weird camera angles and
because of the tank controls like that
it's you're removed enough that like you
can't quite do the thing you need to do
don't just add suspense ashore in the
fact that yeah it's like it's bad yeah
but I wonder if that makes it it's a
pretend this is great questions I like
it's kind of like it's kind of like a 2
a.m. idea
so we've ticked our boxes we've got
Sponge Bob Star Wars Mike's library and
then a pretentious Mike literati that's
right well that's I think I think we
done did it thank you for joining me
today both of you will have to hurry
back next week hopefully he's Oh Mike is
frozen for me is he frozen for you
Austin I have yeah it's a beautiful
smile you're frozen up I know I was
gonna say just a head shot take that
screen guard I think my computer is
actually crash excellent my screen is
actually frozen as well and well on
YouTube just played in for me excellent
it couldn't have been a better freeze
frame no I never looked like that a
freeze frame seriously just look like
you were very happy to be talking to us
so thank you all thank you that's it
from us this week yeah hopefully troll
be back next week that is certainly the
plan going forward but as mentioned we
may eventually have guests if people
schedules too busy all that traveling so
if anyone has any requests for guests
who would in theory have similar roles
to us whether it be directors composes
actors or journalists for sure let me
know what also love to know I don't
usually do that just environment thing
but I would also love to know if anyone
does have a game they can think of that
that is what Austin was asking us about
if that I feel like you've just invited
the comments to be a flood of here are
the journalists I like better than Alana
the game developers I like better than
Mike the composers I like better than
Austin Troy will probably be safe Troy
can stay they'll be a vote for just for
windows with four different choice I'd
still listen to it that's voice
beautiful yeah a show of this let's make
like a supercut of Joel talking to
Booker talking to you know let's let's
create an interesting what's the bad guy
from far cry always forget his name
pagan man pink suit yeah yeah boy ya
know I'd watch that
out off the dock is really just us
complimenting Troy that's how you treat
people you love this you never tell them
nice things while they're here when
they're not of course yeah we just weep
Troy all right we will see you guys next
week
Mike bye